Benjamin is with us in Illinois hi
Benjamin how are you better than I
deserve
how are you Dave just the same sir
what's up awesome
so thank you for taking my call I'm 22
and I wanted to ask what is the best way
to finish my bachelor's in business
administration so we know how bad
student loans are and I agree I hate
that but I don't see myself getting this
degree without taking out at least a
couple loans so I have around two years
left to finish and assuming I don't work
while in college or get any additional
grant why would I assume that our can
die while you're in college I like to
plan for the worst and hope for the best
well I'm a plan for working acknowledges
what I'm gonna plan for okay that's fair
yeah I got a pain for this how that flip
you're gonna pay for it otherwise I'm
not gonna you know I'm not gonna put you
in debt you called Dave Ramsey mmm-hmm
all right so how much does school cost
you know so ten thousand dollars a year
and you need two years so you need 20
grand yes sir
are you living at home yes good and you
can live at home and go to that school
dot no I can't do Oh in Kentucky why is
it in Kentucky you're an Illinois
partly because I wanted to get away from
the city and kind of focus be able to
focus on school without the other
distractions of life okay is there a
Business School in your area that you
can go to uh-huh there are a few seasons
ago I did look and we save a lot of room
and board would be an extra ten to
fifteen thousand if I didn't income you
know basically what you're doing is
you're paying twenty thousand dollars
for your education and you're paying
twenty thousand dollars to get out of
state and go live away from mom and dad
right so we have to decide what our
goals are here goal number one is get
the education goal number two is go have
fun and get out of state
mm-hmm okay I mean that's a secondary
goal right here and I'm sure it's crud
not borrowing money for that okay so do
you have any money at all right now
you're saying cashing him yes sir
so I am currently 74 in that seven four
hundred and then I have about right now
four thousand cash okay you have four
thousand dollars saved towards this
twenty thousand dollar problem or forty
thousand dollar problem right okay
mm-hmm and have you applied for any
scholarships or grants no how is it that
you can go to Kentucky so cheap because
that sounds awfully cheap for an
out-of-state tuition yeah so it's a it's
a private school
and because I'm a member of the Baptist
Church that we go to they do half off
50% off you remember we want a Baptist
member of a Baptist Church we give half
off for students who are involved in
about this church okay cool
was it Asbury no IceBridge method no
it's a Southern Southern Baptist
Theological Seminary always called are
your starting to be a pattern actually
no what setting for business already a
couple mm yeah I already took a few
classes already that's the thing I
already took some online classes and
then I was there for a semester as well
so I did already start great don't
transfer they would transfer to another
place okay so here's the thing where you
graduate from really does not matter as
long as the education is reasonably good
as long as you learn the business
principles that you're supposed to be
learning while you get your degree the
piece of paper has no value at all only
the knowledge that you're going to gain
has pay as now as has value in the
marketplace no one succeeds because they
caught a college degree they succeed
because of their personal character
their drive their ambition and the
knowledge that they gained while getting
a college degree helps them to succeed
okay and that's the way you need to look
at this and so your primary goal is to
get the knowledge that's a primary goal
I can
goal is to move to Kentucky and go to
the Baptist school but I suspect that I
mean you might be able to make let's see
here forty thousand twenty thousand
years there you mean you'd need to make
about two thousand bucks a month while
you're in school that's a lot of work
you can do that impossible but you can
do that and work your way through the
Baptist school or you can make you know
eight hundred bucks a month and nine
hundred bucks a month and live at home
and get through school but uh and you
can make that I mean you could make it
if you just I mean if you're in Kentucky
what city in Kentucky is that in
Louisville okay I mean you can make that
delivering pizza in Louisville but
you're just gonna be working all the
time while you're in school
and if it means that much to you to be
away but keep in mind that you're
spending twenty thousand dollars for
your education and your spending twenty
thousand dollars for your lifestyle well
and so you cannot tie the two together
and say oh I have to do the lifestyle in
order to get the education because we've
established that you can get the
education where you live it's just not
where you want to go so I'm okay if you
do either one you're just gonna be
working your way through I would apply
for five thousand scholarships go to
Anthony O'Neill's website we got ten
thousand scholarships on there we're
giving away ten thousand dollars in
scholarships you might win one of them
one of them's five thousand and there's
225 hundreds you might win one of them
sign up for it there's no purchase
necessary Anthony O'Neill comm on
there's a scholarship search tool on
there is a college calculator tool and
it'll help you to do all of this and get
in there and start some scholarships and
apply for about three hundred of them
and then over the weekend here just
spend the whole freaking weekend filling
out scholarships and get turned down for
most of them but I mean if you got
twenty thousand dollars or fifteen
thousand dollars in scholarships it
changes his whole discussion so yeah
make that your new part-time job first
and then deliver pizzas or blow leaves
off rich people's lawns rich people are
scared leaves get you a leaf blower and
you know there's all kinds of stuff you
can do it's called work man and yeah
you're gonna work or you're gonna go in
debt because you were too lazy to work
but either one of those and then you're
gonna get to work to pay off the debt so
one way or the other you're gonna end up
doing
my man you know you're just kidding
yourself so let's go ahead and just face
some music that's the way I look at it
one of the things I learned to do is to
just Benjamin as I just said debts off
the table once I no longer have the
ability to borrow money because I refuse
to then anything I want to do I have to
figure out another way to do it and all
the sudden you get real creative or you
slow down or you pick different things
and you would have picked otherwise but
you're a student loan looking for a
place to happen right now
if you don't shift some of these
attitudes you started this phone call
with but I think you can and I think you
should you're too bright a young man to
cause to fall in the same trap all these
other groups have in America so don't be
like everybody else dude try being weird